Speaker 1: We had huge news yesterday, which
is that Joe Biden will get an opportunity
to select the first of we don't know how many
Supreme Court justices during his presidency.
We learned yesterday that if Democrats don't
screw it up, and unfortunately, I already
will have an example for you today of a Democrat
who seems to not understand the risks here
and that this could end up getting getting
screwed up.
83 year old Supreme Court Justice Stephen
Breyer plans to retire.
And as a result, Joe Biden will get to replace
a liberal justice with a liberal justice.
And that is an important factor here and that
this will not change the balance of the court,
but it will ensure that Breyer seat will stay
with the left, the Liberals.
Whatever term you want to apply for some period
of time that will be dependent on the age
of the person selected to replace Breyer.
So NBC News reporting Justice Stephen Breyer
to retire from the court, paving the way for
a Biden appointment.
The liberal justices decision to step down
after more than 27 years on the court allows
Biden to appoint a successor who could serve
four decades.
Biden and Breyer are scheduled to appear together
at the White House today as the Supreme Court
will announce his retirement.
That may have happened by the time you listen
to today's show.
Brian is one of three Breyer or rather is
one of the three remaining liberal justices.
His decision to retire after more than 27
years on the court allows Biden to appoint
a successor who could serve for decades in
the short term, maintaining the current six
three split between conservative and liberal
justices.
This is a really important aspect of this
which we're going to talk about.
We're replacing a liberal with a liberal.
It doesn't shift the court.
Trump's big thing was putting in Amy Coney
Barrett to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg, replacing
a liberal with a pretty serious conservative.
Now, Joe Biden previously said he would appoint
a black woman to the Supreme Court, who would
be the first black woman ever on the Supreme
Court.
It does appear as though that is still the
plan.
There has been a shortlist of potential nominees
released and one of the primary names that
really I mean, listen, we don't yet know.
But the person being mentioned as the frontrunner
is Judge Kidd, Tunji Brown Jackson, who was
appointed last year to the U.S. Court of Appeals
in Washington, D.C.
And so you can take a look at that short list
that is out there.
But D.C. Circuit Judge Clayton G. Brown Jackson
at the top of the list.
California Supreme Court Justice Leandra Kruger
is believed to be on the list.
South Carolina U.S. District Court Judge Michelle
Childs on the list and others.
White House Press Secretary Jen Psaki yesterday
asked about Joe Biden's commitment to putting
a black woman on the court, and she had the
following to say Just go ahead.
Speaker 2: Thanks, Chad.
Two subjects.
So let's say hypothetically, a Supreme Court
justice was to retire and announce it on his
or her own terms.
Does President Biden plan to honor his pledge
to nominate a black woman to the court?
Speaker 3: Well, I have commented on this
previously.
The president has stated and reiterated his
commitment to nominating a black woman to
the Supreme Court and certainly stands by
that for today.
Again, I'm just not going to be able to say
anything about any specifics until, of course,
Justice Breyer makes any announcement should
he decide to make an announcement.
Speaker 1: OK, so immediately there is argument,
disagreement, controversy over this.
There are some on the right who were saying
This is racism.
You are.
Preemptively saying I will not consider white
people for the position, therefore it's racist
to say we're going to appoint a black woman
to the Supreme Court now, I think that's a
terribly bad faith argument, and I must give
the following reminder, if not disclaimer,
to the people who may not be familiar with
my view on identity politics.
I am not an identity politics fan.
I am against the use of identity as a cudgel
or to silence or to elevate when it comes
to the world.
And that being said, I recognize that one's
identity can be an interesting and relevant
factor in the exploration of topics of all
sorts.
Economic, social, cultural, whatever the case
may be.
And so for me, these ideas of I will nominate
a black woman.
They're not super interesting to me.
It doesn't I don't like Biden more because
he says I will put a black woman on the court,
but.
I'm now not so deluded as to think that this
would be the same as saying I will only put
a white person on the court.
We have a history in the United States where
we had a Supreme Court for the longest period,
made up exclusively of white men and a history
of enslaving black people in the United States.
So while I am not an identity politics guy,
I recognize that it would be a relevant milestone
for the country to say, Hey, we've had for
hundreds of years, we've had all these different
types of people in the country, and yet we've
never had a black woman on the court.
Now I also would say this is not only restricted
to black women.
What about Native Americans?
What?
What about Asians?
The point here is we can simultaneously be
against the toxic, destructive, counterproductive
identity politics that I've been criticizing
on the program for a very long time and recognize
that wait a second.
We've never had a black woman on the court.
Oh, it would be a relevant milestone to have
won.
Of course, starting from the baseline that
there are countless black women who would
be qualified to be on the court.
That's another aspect to this that the right
is being very bad faith about, which is saying
When you say I'm going to put a black woman
on the court, that's that's the that's a category
which I am going to seek to fill.
You are no longer putting qualified people
there.
You are choosing identity over qualifications.
Now, if there were no qualified black women
in the country, that might be an argument
to be made.
But of course, there are countless qualified
black women to be on the court.
And so the idea that we are sacrificing qualifications
for identity, it also is not the case.
So I hope that it's coming through that we
can be reasonable about this without falling
into these very bad faith arguments that the
right is seeking to make.
I think the bigger concern is if and how Republicans
are going to come up with a way to block this
right.
I mean, I don't know, guys, we're only nine
months from a midterm.
Maybe it's too soon to be confirmed.
Shouldn't the people have a say or maybe are
Macron or cancel culture?
There must be some reason Republicans, you
know, if if a if Breyer announces the retirement
today, when the when the retirement is announced
on a Thursday during winter in the northern
hemisphere.
Marjorie Taylor Greene gets to pick instead
of Biden.
I'm obviously kidding, but they may try to
figure out some way to try to block this.
Now, one other aspect of this is that on the
identity piece, other presidents have done
the same thing just to be thorough on that.
Remember when Donald Trump said this, and
none of the Republicans went crazy?
Speaker 4: I won't be putting forth a nominee
next week.
It will be a woman.
Speaker 1: Wow.
And the crowd cheered for that.
It was OK when Trump said, It's going to be
a woman or remember this.
This was this was Ronald Reagan.
This is Tom Brokaw who remembers this one.
Speaker 2: Ronald Reagan today promised to
appoint a woman to the Supreme Court if he's
elected president.
Speaker 1: Whoa, hold.
Isn't that isn't that identity?
They're they're total hypocrites.
They didn't care when Trump did it.
OK, fine.
We know that.
Next thing I can imagine, in all seriousness,
not wanting a seat at the current Supreme
Court table, let me explain what I mean.
We have a hyperpartisan court right now.
We have a court that at six three is making
rulings, obviously based on Partizan politics
and not simple sober interpretations of the
law.
The court is a six three majority right now
for the Conservatives, and it will remain
a six three majority.
Once Breyer is replaced with whoever Joe Biden
nominates, I'm not sure I would even want
to be part of a court where my opinion would
almost literally never matter if you had a
five four conservative court with Justice
Roberts, who has sided with liberals in the
past.
It leaves the possibility that when you put
in a black woman to be part of some votes
that will have an impact and make a difference,
there is no chance of that for as long as
this is a six three court.
Now, I'm not literally saying whoever is nominated
should turn it down.
But I could understand why a nominee might
think, you know, it might be better for my
legacy not to be nominated right now.
Just just a thought that I'm having.
And of course, if the person is young enough,
they could be appointed.
They could be confirmed now in this kind of
futile six three situation and down the line.
Circumstances change, and they end up being
part of some impactful decisions.
Last thing, Republicans are also now polling
this is Joe Biden going to get rid of the
problematic Kamala Harris by putting her on
the court.
Here's Peter Alexander asking about that.
Speaker 2: There were none of that you can
share.
Speaker 3: I'm not going to detail internal
planning from here now.
OK.
Speaker 2: And let me ask you a couple of
other questions.
Is there any scenario in which the president
would select his vice president, Kamala Harris
for the Supreme Court?
Speaker 3: Again, I'm not going to speak to
any considerations preparations list.
And as we've stated earlier and you heard
the president say it is, there's a long history
of Supreme Court justices determining when
they may retire then.
Speaker 1: So because Jen Psaki didn't rule
it out, then Peter Doocy followed up about
the same thing.
And then it becomes a story that it's like
a runaway train
Speaker 3: talked about isn't an initial package.
Speaker 2: OK, thank you, guys.
Thank you.
When you were asked about the vice president
possibly being selected as a Supreme Court
nominee, he said, you're not going to speak
to any considerations.
Does that mean she is being considered?
Speaker 3: Again, Peter, I'm not going to
speak to the reports of a Supreme Court Justice
retirement that hasn't been announced.
Speaker 1: So and then Fox News was talking
about this, and it took on a life of its own
absolute last thing on this.
Democrats might still screw it up, and there
is a tweet that exemplifies this from Jennifer
Haberkorn quoting Senator Dianne Feinstein.
Apparently, Senator Dianne Feinstein doesn't
see a rush to confirm a Breyer replacement,
saying with six months until Justice Breyer
departs the court.
The Senate Judiciary Committee will have ample
time to hold hearings on President Biden's
nominee.
I really hope that they don't take all of
that time because that's exactly how you get
into a situation that allows Republicans to
say, now it's rushed.
Now it's right before an election.
We can't do this.
Don't do it, Democrats, please don't screw
it up.